ich weiß nicht ob sie liebe zu schauen
dann zuschauer hätte tennis geschaut
haben der titel mama maria de ist für
mich eine abwertung der leistung hat
erna maria die hat nichts mehr mit dem
finale geschafft aber trotzdem viel
erreicht und überall heißt es der tennis
da sei mama maria sie sehen dass jedes
hat haben wir auch geschrieben mütter
das aufgeschrieben weil sie mama ist
aber damit werden wir doch ihre
leistungen ab bin irgendwie schwingt für
mich weil mama maria mit ja erstaunlich
dass sie das schafft obwohl sie mutter
ist und es schwingt für mich auch so
müssen mit ihr passen eigentlich auf die
kinder auf wenn mama s karriere machen
will und es schwingt auch mit der mama
müsste doch jetzt eigentlich jetzt an
filmchen und den kleinen spielen und
kuchen backen aber mama kann tennis
spielen ist ja krass wenn männer nehme
ich da sagen wir das nicht das heißt die
papa federer und es geht ja nicht nur im
sport es geht ja auch in der politik
eigentlich überall papa habe ich nie
gehört aber mama annalena baerbock er
das hören wir ständig und das ist
irgendwie für mich ein spiegel unserer
gesellschaft ist ist noch immer nicht
normal dass mamas noch etwas anderes
machen als mahnmal sein und das
vielleicht so überraschung vieler auch
noch erfolgreich lasst uns doch mama nur
einfach dann verwenden wenn es um dinge
geht nicht um die karriere ganz so wie
wir das bei männern auch machen ich habe
die überschrift ganz anders gelesen ich
habe ich habe es eigentlich als stolz
gelesen zumal sie das selbst immer
wieder gesagt hat das ist für sie das
größte sei und sie hat das so natürlich
präsentiert dass sie selbstverständlich
jetzt hier gewinnen will und trotzdem
kinder und familie für sie das größte
sind ich habe das nicht als widerspruch
gelesen bei männern weiß ich oftmals gar
nicht ob sie kinder haben das ist ja
interessant ist
ich glaube
ich glaube wir machen uns eine illusion
wenn wir glauben dass wir tatsächlich
eine gleichberechtigte gesellschaft sind
ich nicht dass die technik die
verbindung von kindergarten zu müttern
ist eine andere und ich fürchte sie
bleibt noch eine ganze weile und das ist
eine relativ einfache ansicht ich kann
mir sagen dass meiner lebenswirklichkeit
meine tochter wenn ich im feld danach
mussten die
jungs sind noch eher die mama kinder
oder aber ganz ehrlich ich teile die
these also ich finde mama ist was
starkes ich bin aber ob man für jeden
zusammenhang verwenden muss die frage
darf man ja mal ständigen weit dehnen
stellen die sie dann bitte an der stelle
aber ich finde auch nicht abwertend
meine mama zu sein dass also
das ist doch wahr aber es schwingt immer
dieses buch schafft es trotz dieser
stellt gas für uns frauen mehr mit als
für männer oder hand also erstmal ohne
die vielen mamas auf dieser welt gibt es
kein leben jetzt wollen wir mal erst mal
fest aber ich bin froh dass wir in
unserem land noch mama und papa sagen
dürfen allen anderen ländern wird
darüber diskutiert ob man das schafft
das manchmal noch ein papa sagt ja also
da bin ich froh dass wir darüber noch
reden können aber im endeffekt sollte
das keine geschlechterfrage sein sodass
seite einfach danach reden was jemand
kann die container spielen dann soll
sich das spielen und wenn sie damit
erfolg hat dann ist das etwas tolles und
wenn sie sehr natürlich selber sagt sich
immer als mama denn vielleicht auch
selber immer gesagt hat dann wird das
vielleicht damit zusammen hängen aber
eigentlich sollte man sich immer den
menschen angucken und nicht das
geschlecht denn das ist glaube ich das
entscheiden und wenn wir ich sehe dass
zwar leider aus meiner arbeit auch immer
wieder dass ich merke dass das zwar nach
außen demonstriert wird aber ist noch
lange nicht da ist dass wir wirklich
eine absolute gleichberechtigung haben
es ist leider noch viel viel viel viel
viel zu tun um das zu erreichen da
können wir quoten machen und und und und
denn ein langer weg wissen aber wir sind
ja auf dem weg dahin ich hoffe bloß dass
wir uns auf dem weg dahin nicht mit
vielen vielen dingen verlieren und
unsere gesellschaft mama maria für sie
ein lob oder
wichtigsten zu haben aber ist das ein
kompliment denn wir alle titel mama
maria und vielleicht denkt man in diesem
moment gar nicht darüber nach was hat
man da gesagt also mama maria sonst
wahrscheinlich auch und von diesen mamma
mia kommen oder so dass es davon
vielleicht zum arbeitet liter
ob sie nun mutter ist oder nicht spielt
er für diesen tennis erfolg keine rolle
ja und ich glaube also jetzt in meinem
bekanntenkreis
ich würde mich jetzt nicht so drüber
unterhalten und jetzt mutter ist oder
nicht sie ist eine gute tennisspielerin
aber punkten unterhalten sich darüber
dass sie vor einem jahr glaube ich nie
gekommen ist oder vor zwei und jetzt in
seiner topform ist das ist natürlich
nicht so gut aber
wir müssen zum ende kaum ein hoch auf
das royale brautpaar für den nach acht
vielen dank an meine gäste ist wenn der
traum diskussion schönen abend noch